the Grammy Awards turned into a powerful
night for women and rap music host
Alicia Keys set the tone last night when
she introduced four high-profile women
former first lady Michelle Obama stunned
everybody
Lady Gaga Jada Pinkett Smith and
Jennifer Lopez spoke about female
empowerment Entertainment Tonight
co-host Kevin Frazier was backstage for
all the excitement he joins us from the
et set in Los Angeles Kevin good morning
what a night in a great show it was an
amazing night and you know seeing the
former first lady was just the first of
many surprises you know for the first
time rap artists won some of Grammys top
prizes but the night really did belong
to the ladies thirty-one women took home
trophies including Lady Gaga who nabbed
two for her stars born hit shallow
[Music]
[Applause]
lady got that turned shallow into a high
energy rock anthem at Sunday night's
Grammy Awards channeling a message of
female empowerment that resonated
through the night she was one of three
female artists who took the stage with
the night's biggest surprise guest
Michelle Obama music shows us that all
of it matters
every story within every voice every
note within every song that right ladies
how was it being a part of that amazing
it was incredible I'm having so much fun
I feel so blessed cardi B made Grammy
history is the first solo woman to win
the Grammy for Best Rap Album in fact
most album categories including R&B pop
vocal and jazz vocal were won by female
artists and Kacey Musgraves won not only
best country album but an album of the
year this is America childish gambino
became the first rap artist to win for
record and song of the year for this is
America a song about gun violence and
racial discrimination
Gambino was a no-show
despite winning a total of four awards
until last night the Grammys had a
history of overlooking rap artists in
its top categories Drake who won for
best rap song used his acceptance speech
to encourage other artists while calling
out the academy if there's people who
have regular jobs who are coming out in
the rain in the snow spending their
hard-earned money to buy tickets to come
to your shows you don't need this right
here I promise you how you already won
now the night also included a number of
tributes to female artists including
Dolly Parton and Diana Ross in our next
hour we'll have more of my backstage
interviews including would Alicia Keys
told me about whether she'll be back to
host again next year
Fionna yeah I'd like her to host that
and the Oscar in the next hour